después de semanas de discusiones
diplomáticas y logísticas un equipo de
expertos del organismo internacional de
energía atómica ha llegado finalmente a
sap orilla la ciudad del sur de ucrania
alberga la mayor central nuclear de
europa un lugar que ha sido objeto de
ataques de ambos bandos desde que rusia
invadió el país a principios de este año
el principal temor por supuesto es un
accidente nuclear que agravaría un
conflicto ya desastroso evitar un
incidente en la central es lo que espera
el equipo del oiea
y creo que es muy importante establecer
con toda claridad que mi misión es una
misión técnica es una misión que busca
prevenir un accidente nuclear y
preservar esta importante central
nuclear más grande de europa guns
pero si los expertos serán capaces de
lograr sus objetivos es una incógnita en
las últimas 24 horas los funcionarios
locales controlados por moscú afirmaron
que las tropas ucranianas lanzaron
ataques con drones contra el edificio
administrativo y el centro de
entrenamiento de la planta ucrania por
su parte acusó a los rusos de bombardear
las carreteras de acceso a la planta
también está en duda la duración del
viaje el organismo internacional de
control nuclear espera establecer una
misión permanente en la planta lo que
sólo podría ocurrir si cesan los
combates en los alrededores mientras
tanto ucrania ha dejado claro que quiere
que la misión de la agencia conduzca a
una retirada completa de las tropas
rusas